there's an internet rumor on Reddit that  if you watch the famous idiosyncrasies  scene in Goodwill Hunting that you can  actually see a subtle wobbling up and  down because the camera operator was  laughing uncontrollably right along with  you and Robin Williams confirm or deny  on that I don't know we could check I  wouldn't be surprised he refused to fart  in the Sleep one night it was so loud  about the dog up  Robin made everybody laugh I'm in  uncontrollably and when he would see  people's energy flagging he would just  launch into like 10 minutes of stand up  he was the biggest you know comedian in  the world and actor in the world and  that level of like I don't know  leadership kind of like and attention  and love love coming from him was just  like well you know everybody was ready  to like work for another 12 hours I mean  he was just amazing  [Laughter]